nezuko is the special demon The Chosen
demon that muzan has been looking for
for 1 000 years she is the key to
everything and the true nature of her
power could be crucial for defeating
muzon or it could end up being the very
thing that muza needs to destroy all
demon Slayers and become the master of
Japan by the end of this video you will
know everything you need to know about
nezuko's special demon power why she is
so important to muzon and how she was
able to do the impossible to conquer the
sun you guys know the drill if you enjoy
our demons our content and you want to
see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment right now it helps me
out with that YouTube algorithm and if
you're one of the over 50 of people who
watch my videos but haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a huge favor
and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications subscribing
on YouTube is completely free but it
helps me out a lot lot nezukol was born
to a family of charcoal Merchants who
lived a modest life up on a mountain
nezuko was the second of six children
she has one older brother tanjiro who is
about two years older than her and four
younger siblings nezuko's father tanturo
was frail and sickly for most of his
adult life so as the eldest child
tanjiro was forced to engage in
difficult adult duties at an early age
even as a pre-teen tanjiro would carry
charcoal to the nearest town on his back
and sell it and he would then bring the
money back to his family all by himself
as the second oldest sibling nezuko also
did her best to help out the family and
she would often make sacrifices such as
constantly mending old clothes and
refusing to buy new ones so that her
younger siblings would have plenty of
food to eat even though nezuko's father
was frail he was still a positive
influence on all his children and he was
an exemplary role model as the oldest
son tanjiro was a especially close to
his father and he learned not only about
the family charcoal business from
tanjuro but he also learned a ritual
dance called hinokami kagura a dance
that has been passed on from generation
to generation within the Commodore
family for centuries this dance would
turn out to be extremely important to
the story because it actually contained
within it the fundamental movements of
the original breathing style Sun
breathing so this means that nezuko
comes from a family of sun breathers
people who have practiced the art of sun
breathing for over four centuries and
they've been doing it ever since the
original user of sun breathing
yorichitsugikuni personally demonstrated
its techniques to nezuko's ancestor
sumiyoshi unfortunately nezuko's father
tanjiro died at a young age and this
meant that as the eldest siblings
tanjiro and nezuko had to take on even
more responsibility despite being only
pre-teens themselves the rest of the
Commodore family came came together
supported each other and managed to
survive in harmony even after the tragic
death of tanjuro although every family
member had to work hard and although
they all had to make sacrifices the
family managed to survive and thrive on
their own up in the mountains sadly all
of this changed one night after tanjiro
went down to the nearest town to sell
charcoal during a snowstorm the snow
slowed tanjiro down and he found himself
still on the road late at night he
decided to spend the night in the home
of a man he knew and then he continued
home early in the morning tragically by
the time Tanja returned to the Commodore
family home all of his family members
were dead except for nezuko nezuka was
injured but her body was still warm saw
a shocked and heartbroken tanjiro tried
to carry her on his back in an attempt
to find a doctor who could treat her and
potentially save her life tanjiro
believed that his family must have been
attacked by a hungry bear or something
but then as he is carrying there's a
call she begins to scream she also grows
sharp monstrous fangs and her eyes
develop cat-like slits she is turning
into a demon Tanja was happy to see that
she's alive and he tries to embrace her
but let's go attacks him and nearly
devours her own brother tanjiro tells
nezuko to fight the urge to become a
demon and his words seem to get through
to her because she begins to cry and an
internal struggle begins to rage inside
of her in that moment the water
hashiragiu appears he attempts to kill
nezuko as soon as he spots her but
tanjiro doesn't want his sister to die
so he actively tries to protect her from
guil explains that nezuko must be
eliminated because demon blood got into
her wound and she is now transforming
into a demon as we now know the demon
who attacked the Commodore family and
whose blood nezuko ingested was the
progenitor of the Demons muzan kibutuji
himself this is how man-eating demons
multiply and she must be killed
immediately before she has a chance to
hurt someone at least that's giyu's
argument but tanjiro insists that nezuko
would never eat anyone and he refuses to
back down he is determined to find a
cure for his sister and to turn her back
into a human now guio doesn't think this
is even possible and he still intends to
kill nezuko tanjiro tries to fight him
but Geo is a far more skilled and
experienced Warrior and so he manages to
get the better of tanjiro however you is
shocked to see that nezuko actually
decides to get involved in the fight in
order to protect her brother from guiyu
newly transformed demons are starving
for energy and they often need even
their own family members in order to get
stronger this instinct to consume human
flesh immediately regardless of whom the
flesh belongs to overcomes the vast
majority of demons but for some reason
nezuko is different not only does she
refuse to consume her brother's flesh
but she is actively fighting to protect
him Kyu is so shocked by what's
happening that he decides that tanjiro
and nezuko might really be different
they appear to be somehow special and so
he decides to spare nezuko's life he
tells tanjiro to take her and go see an
old man named sakonji urokodaki sakonji
is Gio's old master and the former water
hashira and after burying their deceased
family members tanjano and nezuko set
out to find the former water hashira
because demons cannot be exposed to
sunlight tanjiro places nezuko inside a
large basket and carries her on his
shoulders during the day they eventually
meet sakonji who was contacted by guiyu
earlier and informed about tanjiro and
nezuko's unique situation Kyu firmly
believes that there is something special
about nezuko and he is willing to put
his own life on the line for that belief
in fact tanjirogiu and sakonji all vowed
that they will take take their own lives
if nezuko ever attacks a human and so
under sakonji's guidance tanjiro
undergoes Demon Slayer training on Mount
sagiri as for nezuko she just sleeps
through all of tanjiro's intense
training which takes two whole years to
complete during the two years that
nezuko slept sakonji also used hypnosis
to instill nezuko with the idea that all
human beings are members of her family
and that she must protect them all by
killing the demons who are trying to
hurt them unlike other demons who need
to consume human flesh in order to
replenish their energy nezuko is able to
recover her energy by simply sleeping a
lot meaning that she doesn't need to
consume humans in order to survive I
mean the fact that at this point in the
story nazuku has been a demon for like
two years but has never consumed any
human flesh is already a huge deal and
it makes her different from virtually
every other demon in existence and the
fact that she protects humans while
fighting against her own fellow demons
is so rare that the Hashim and other
important members of the Demon Slayer
core genuinely believed that something
like this was impossible and yet nezuko
has been defying people's expectations
of what a demon is since the very
beginning and she continues to do so
throughout the entire series nezuko is
an extremely special demon The Chosen
demon and up to this point we've only
scratched the surface of how special she
truly is now after becoming a demon
nezuko does undergo a real
transformation not only physically but
also mentally her behavior changes and
she goes from the mature second oldest
child of the Commodore family to being a
very quiet and childlike girl once she
becomes a demon she also isn't able to
speak normally although she is able to
communicate in other ways including
making sounds and gestures she also
appears to have lost a portion of her
memories from back when she was still
human leading to her developing a
simpler and more childlike Persona
Tamayo believes that the reason why
nezuku reverted to a childlike state
after becoming a demon is because she
was intensely focusing most of her
Consciousness inward in an attempt to
control her demonic urges and to escape
muzan's telepathic control and so what
was left on the outside was just a
simple childlike personality but
although nezuko is special and although
some of the changes she undergoes are
indeed mental in nature nezuko does also
experience some common physical changes
that are associated with becoming a
demon this includes growing sharp Fang
like teeth and sharp claw-like nails as
well as developing superhuman physical
strength and speed she demonstrates this
superhuman physical strength as early as
chapter 2 of the story where we see her
kick another Demon's head clean off its
body she is also able to alter the size
of her body and make herself smaller
which allows tanjiro to carry her inside
a wooden box on his back in order to
help her hide from the Sun the one thing
that all demons have in common is their
weakness to sunlight demons die if their
bodies are exposed to sunlight their
bodies will literally burn up and
disintegrate the most common way that
demon stairs go about killing demons is
relieving them of their heads using
special nichidin blades but the very
strongest demons like muzon have
actually figured out a way to stay alive
even if they are beheaded by a nitroen
blade nevertheless although these few
select demons are able to survive even
losing their heads to a nitrogen weapon
no demon is able to survive being
exposed to the Sun or at least that's
what we thought but more on that in a
little bit as tanjiro progresses in his
Demon Slayer Journey nezuko finds
herself actually emerging from her box
and actively helping her brother in
combat At first she fights exclusively
by using her superhuman physical
strength and her sharp nails she is also
able to tap into the supernatural
regenerative power that all demons
possess and as a result she is able to
take on a lot of damage in battle and
still keep fighting even if she loses
entire limbs she can use her demonic
regeneration to grow them back extremely
quickly which is the kind of ability
that an ordinary human can only dream of
as nezuko continues to use and develop
her demonic abilities she eventually
unlocks an extremely powerful and useful
blood demon art called blood burst
even though nezuko is herself a demon
her blood demon art only hurts other
demons she can set her own body on fire
and this fire can be used to burn demons
and disrupt their regeneration abilities
while being completely harmless to
humans the Flames can actually help
humans by burning up demonic poison
inside of their bodies without harming
them which is what nezuko does during
the Entertainment District arc when she
Burns guitero's poison out of inosuke
and tengen's body literally saving their
lives in the process chapters 83 and 84
is when we really begin to understand
nezuko's true power and her full
potential when she finds herself in a
dangerous and life-threatening situation
nezuko transforms into her true demon
form her body becomes larger and more
muscular she is covered in markings that
resemble Vines and a horn appears on the
right side of her forehead in this
powered up form no becomes much stronger
and faster and she becomes an incredibly
powerful fighter her regeneration
abilities also become far more powerful
to the point that she is able to go
toe-to-toe against an upper Moon and Doc
even says that nezuko's regeneration
abilities now rival those of an upper
moon but there is also a downside to
this power-up when she first attains
this form nezuka loses control of
herself and goes berserk she begins
acting like a wild and ruthless demon
and she starts craving human blood and
flesh much more than usual normally
nezuku is able to effectively resist the
instinct to consume humans so much so
that she is even able to resist sonami's
marichi blood which is completely
resistible to most demons however in her
powered up demon form nezuko loses
control and she nearly attacks a human
luckily tanjiro is able to calm his
sister down by singing her a lullaby
from their childhood as the story
progresses nezuko is able to control
herself more effectively and she is able
to use elements of this powered up
demonic form in battle without losing
control it is important to remember that
if nezuko had gone on to hurt a human in
this form tanjiro giyu and the former
water hashira sakonji would have had to
take their own lives I know I mentioned
this before but I just wanted to remind
everyone again because it's such a huge
deal but okay up to this point we've
seen that nezuko is a powerful demon who
is also extremely unique she is unique
in that she can survive without
devouring humans and that she actually
fights to protect humans against her own
kind this certainly makes nezuko special
and unique but it still doesn't make her
the legendary chosen demon that muzan
has been looking for for 1 000 years
so what is it that makes nezuko so
special and important to muzon and why
is he determined to find her at any cost
in chapters 126 and 127 of the manga
nezuko manages to do the impossible she
becomes the first demon who is able to
survive after being directly exposed to
sunlight when tanjiro isn't able to hide
her away from the sun in time because he
was too busy defeating upper Moon 4
huntengu the light of dawn makes direct
contact with her skin and at first it
begins to Scorch her demon body as
expected but then something shocking
happens instead of completely
disintegrating in the sunlight nezuko is
somehow able to develop an immunity to
the sun her skin goes back to normal and
she is able to walk in the sun normally
without being harmed by it despite the
fact that she is still very much a demon
in short mezuko somehow manages to come
conquer the sun oh and she is now also
able to speak again this shocking
development is not only a massive deal
for nezuko tanjiro and the demon Slayers
it is also an absolutely huge
development for the progenerative of the
Demons muzon ever since he first became
a demon around 1 000 years ago muzan has
been looking for a way to conquer the
Sun so that he could move about freely
in the daytime just like he does in the
night time muzan believes himself to be
a fundamentally Superior life form and
in many ways he is superior to humans
his demonic abilities have allowed muzan
to live for an entire Millennium they
provided him with superhuman strength
they gave him the ability to create more
demons and bend them to his will and so
on but even though muzon claims to be
superior to humans this narrative always
had one glaring hole in it even the
weakest and most unremarkable human can
still move about freely in the daylight
and enjoy everything that the world has
to offer during the day but moves on
despite all his strength and power and
the ability to live forever doesn't have
the ability to move around freely in the
sunlight he has spent centuries trying
to find a cure to this weakness he had
tried every possible remedy including
attempting to find the legendary blue
Spider Lily a flower that he believed
would help him conquer the sun he has
also been turning many humans into
demons in the hopes that one of them
would eventually develop on immunity to
the Sun and now finally one of the
people he forcibly turned into a demon
developed that coveted immunity
managed to conquer the sun this is what
muzon has been waiting for even though
both gyoko and Han Tengu were defeated
inside the swordsmith village muzon is
not disappointed instead he is happy
because he now believes that if he can
get to nezuko and consume her he will be
able to conquer the sun just like she
did and then he will truly become the
perfect creature a truly Superior life
form muzon gives up his thousand year
long search for the blue Spider Lily and
he puts all of his energy into getting a
hold of nezuko and consuming her there
are multiple theories about why nezuko
in particular turned out to be the
chosen demon the first demon who was
able to conquer the sun after 1 000
years she was of course turned into a
demon by muzon himself but so were
nearly all the other demons in existence
today with the exception of yushiro and
tamayo's Cat who were turned into Demons
by Tamayo herself so the fact that she
was turned into a demon by muzon using
muzan's own blood doesn't actually make
nezuko special what does make her
special is her incredible willpower and
her family's connection to the original
breath of the sun user yorichi tsugikuni
nezuku's ancestor sumiyoshi was a friend
of yorichi and he learned to perform the
fundamental forms of sun breathing from
yorichi himself he then passed these
forms on from generation to generation
of his family as a ritual dance called
hinokami kagura until that knowledge
eventually reached nezuko's father
tanduro and her brother tanjiro nezuko
herself is not a user of sun breathing
even though she is aware of its
existence since she grew up with it
within the Commodore household perhaps
just merely witnessing the forms of sun
breathing triggered some sort of special
demon resistance power within nezuko or
perhaps she is just extremely stubborn
or perhaps she is just built different
seriously she may have a unique physical
structure that triggered a mutation
within muzan's demon blood and this
mutation led her to develop immunity to
sunlight light this may be the same
unique feature that made the Commodore
family able to perform Sun breathing in
the first place even though every other
demons there except for yorichi failed
to learn it and they had to learn
derivative Styles instead maybe there is
something special within the Commodore
bloodline that makes their family
compatible with sun breathing and that
very factor is what triggered the
mutation that allowed demon nezuko to
conquer the sun there is no 100 clear
explanation for this but it would make
sense if Sun breathing and conquering
the sun Were Somehow connected what do
you guys think why was nezuko able to
conquer the Sun and is there some
specific reason that made her The Chosen
demon was it directly related to Sun
breathing definitely let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
below if you're looking for an epic
demon Star video to watch next check out
my video explaining all 16 breathing
Style files in Demon Slayer including of
course the original style Sun breathing
Link in the description and on screen if
you enjoyed this video be sure to leave
a like right now for the YouTube
algorithm and if you are one of the over
50 of people who watch my videos but
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a huge favor and make this the
video do you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications